thomas il est une heure du matin chez
vous à washington les américains vont
enfin se coucher avec un nouveau
président quelle est l'atmosphère autour
de vous après de la maison blanche après
cette folle journée
pas sûr que les américains qu'ils soient
rassemblés ici vont se coucher tout de
suite grégory il ya encore plusieurs
centaines de personnes qui sont
rassemblées on est à proximité de la
maison blanche
en fait dès l'annoncé à la mi journée ce
samedi de la victoire de joe biden par
les médias américains
plusieurs milliers de personnes ont
afflué ici pour venir célébrer la
victoire du candidat démocrate et de sa
colistière kamala harris et aussi pour
célébrer il faut bien le dire la défaite
de donald trump
beaucoup de personnes ici se disait
soulagé ils nous ont expliqué qu'ils
avaient mal vécu ces quatre années de
mandat de donald trump est aussi ces
quatre jours interminables pour certains
quatre jours avec les yeux rivés vers
l'été la télévision américaine à suivre
l'évolution des cartes et de ces états
qui basculent du rouge au bleu du bleu
au rouge finalement il aura donc fallu
attendre ce samedi pour connaître le
vainqueur de cette élection avec les
annonces et donc par les médias
américains je propose d'écouter quelques
réactions récoltées ces dernières heures
aux états unis avec d'un côté des
supporters de joe biden forcément très
heureux de l'autre de supporters de
donald trump vous l'imaginez forcément
déçu fait l'élection by donne mais on
fait aussi le fait de ne plus avoir à
faire à donald trump le paie tout
simplement meilleurs sans lui nous
devons donner un peu de décence aux
états unis et je pense que donald trump
a été une source d'embarras
c'est donc une chance pour les états
unis de retrouver leur place vous voyez
il devrait mener l'exemple moralement et
pas seulement par la puissance regardez
ça c'est magnifique
voilà à quoi ressemble la démocratie
voilà à quoi ça ressemble quand on a une
élection équitable
ça m'émeut parce que c'est injuste
c'est injuste et fort qu'ils peuvent
mettre quelqu'un à la maison blanche
mais 70 millions de personne n'y croit
pas et je n'y croirai jamais quand on
montrera je serai toujours soucieux par
rapport ce qu'il va se passer c'est un
juge les résultats sont faux ils ne sont
pas vraies ils peuvent bien dire qu'ils
sont vrais ils ne le sont pas je ne leur
fais pas confiance tout est faux alors
ce qui a permis de mettre un terme au
suspens celle et l'actualisation des
chiffres dans l'état de pennsylvanie où
joe biden a été donné en tête à la mi
journée donc ce samedi par les médias
américains une avance suffisante pour ne
plus être en mesure d'être rattrapé par
son concurrent et depuis l'état du
nevada a également été octroyés par les
médias américains
on al'avantage de joe biden joe biden
qui a donc pris la parole vous l'avez
dit c'est aux alentours de 20h40 heure
locale 2h30 environ 1 heure française
depuis la ville de wilmington dans
l'état du delaware il a appelé à l'unité
parce que c'est véritablement le
chantier numéro 1 qui attend le futur
président des états unis
rassembler un pays très divisé et que
cette élection n'aura pas rassembler non
plus on écoute donc joe biden je crois
aux possibilités de ce pays
nous sommes toujours tourné vers
l'avenir devant une amérique plus libre
et plus juste devant une amérique qui
créent des emplois avec dignité et
respect devant une amérique qui guérit
des maladies comme le cancer et la
maladie d'alzheimer devant une amérique
qui ne laisse jamais personne derrière
devant une amérique qui d'un mot donne
jamais qui ne cède jamais négliger
après comme je suis fier de la coalition
que nous avons mis en place la plus
large et la plus diverse de l'histoire
démocrates républicains indépendants
progressiste modéré conservateur jeunes
vieux citadins banlieusards ruraux aux
gays hétéros transsexuels blancs latinos
asiatiques amérindiens la communauté
afro américaine s'est à nouveau levé
pour moi tu as toujours assurer mes
arrières et je vais assurer les tiens
[Applaudissements]
répondez la fois répondait la fois que
dieu vous aime tous
que dieu bénisse l'amérique et que dieu
protège le trou merci merci merci
[Applaudissements]
joe biden qui a également annoncé qu'il
allait mettre en place une cellule de
crise contre la pandémie de kobe de 19 à
compter de ce lundi aux états unis alors
concernant donald trump
lorsque la nouvelle a été annoncée par
les médias américains la nouvelle de la
victoire de joe biden donald trump est
en train de jouer au golf il ya des
images qui circulent on voit le l'actuel
locataire de la maison blanche près de
sa voiturette de golf au moment-même
donc où les médias ont fait cette
annonce on sait donald trump conteste
l'issue de ce scrutin conteste sa
défaite et revendique même sa victoire
écoutez ce cas a publié sur twitter le
président des états unis il ya quelques
heures maintenant des tweets qui ont de
nouveau pour certains étaient signalées
par twitter on écoute les observateurs
n'ont pas été autorisés à entrer dans
les salles de comptage
j'ai gagné l'élection j'ai obtenu 71
millions de votes légaux il s'est passé
de mauvaises choses que nos observateurs
n'étaient pas autorisés à voir
cela ne s'était jamais produit
auparavant des millions de bulletins de
vote par correspondance ont été envoyés
à des gens qui ne les avait jamais
demandé 71 millions de votes légaux le
plus grand nombre de votes jamais
enregistré pour un président en exercice
alors malgré les recours juridiques qui
pourraient déposer
président des états unis et le camp des
républicains certains dirigeants
étrangers ont d'ores et déjà félicité
joe biden pour sa victoire c'est le cas
par exemple des manuels macro et
d'autres dirigeants européens pense par
exemple à angela merkel merci thomas
bonnet pour ce point complet en direct
de washington